he is about to embark on a new project
one of singular importance the Lord of
the Rings the rings of power was built
on a series of fascinating auditions
most of them involved an amount of
secrecy that we're not sure we've seen
before what are some of the wildest
audition stories from the rings of power
cast stick around to find out we face it
that our hearts even bigger in our feet
number one morbid Clark describes her
audition process as long long very long
and spanned three countries she said
that it started off in London then went
to LA and then finished off in Barcelona
with Jay and all his crew there were
kind of two scenes one of which was with
elrond and one of which was with
hellbrand the one elronda auditioned
which we didn't shoot for a long time
there was such a relief when that scene
was finally shot audition was finally
over yeah number two we know Emma
Horvath for her role in rings of power
but her journey with the show started
with considerably more mystery when
asked about her audition process Emma
said my casting process was two tapes I
got lucky it was shorter than most
people's I was hoping that my character
was a dwarf I played a dwarf In My
School Musical when I was 10 years old
so I thought I'd get another go I think
that's that's cool number three Ismail
Cruz Cordova says about his audition
experience it's like seven months
something like that his first audition
was in New York then he ended up having
a couple of auditions in LA and then he
wound up in South Africa for another
project he was doing but unfortunately
that's when he got his first rejection
and I was very ferocious about it I said
no I'm we're gonna keep fighting for
this day the show Runners had to send an
email that didn't really go his way
listen you're wonderful but like it's
not going your direction but then there
was a Twist Cordova was told actually
we're gonna screen test Five Guys and
we'll give you a chance he went to New
Zealand pretending he didn't care but of
course he cared a lot and then the rest
was history he got the role and what day
was he here number four when asked about
his audition experience Charles explains
mine was very straightforward I'd I
submitted a tape and um that was it it
was quite a quick turnaround I hear
others were less quick his audition was
pretty basic and not nearly as chaotic
as some of his co-stars he also said I
only knew who I was playing a couple of
weeks after being cast when I was told I
hadn't heard the name celebremboar
before so I looked it up and I was very
pleased once I realized what the role
was and yes
it very well could be number five
Benjamin Walker brings us the role of
gilgalod in rings of power when asked
about his audition experience he said I
sent a tape and then months went by I
completely forgot about the job he'd
gotten a call from the production team
saying so we're going another way with
the other character do you want this one
and I was like yeah but I was also
nervous about it yeah no kidding all
other senses sleep the eye of Hope is
first to awaken number six Sarah's
wangabani's role brought a very quick
change to her life when she was suddenly
asked to move to a different continent
here's the story I did a self tape I did
a one self tape for the for the role
casting a big show like this takes time
so the actor went along with their life
but then they got a phone call on a
Thursday asking for them to fly to New
Zealand for the Sunday to start the job
so um I was like oh okay when they got
the first two episodes they didn't
actually see the name of the character
that they'd auditioned for which led
them to assume oh okay I'm not in in the
in the show yet and then someone said no
no this is your character number seven
another long one surprise surprise when
asked what her audition experience was
like NASA ninboniardi described it as
months long I think my first one was
April 2019 and that spanned four
auditions three of them were taped
because I was traveling the world for
various other things there was an
in-person audition in London months
later there was a zoom call with
showrunners and then a month later the
news that they had to move to New
Zealand for the role came we all had
pseudonyms at the time so we didn't when
we auditioned we didn't have our
character actual character names but
there were actual sides that existed in
the show for me if you choose to stand
with me and fight this
will no longer be a reminder of our
Frailty number eight tairo muhafin
brings us the role of Theo when asked
about the unusual story around his
audition here's what he had to say he
was long and funnily enough my older
brother Tobias actually got the audition
for the role before I did so a week
beforehand they had sent the audition
being like yeah we want to look at
Tobias for this role and he put down a
self tape and then they came back a week
later being like actually let's try Tyro
because he's younger they did an
audition tape heard silence for months
and then all of a sudden found out
they'd been shortlisted that was
exciting in itself once things started
moving fast they did not stop even after
months of moving so slow I found myself
in New Zealand doing a screen test
number nine Dylan Smith was already
undergoing a huge life change when he
got the call for the role here's what he
had to say about the process I went from
being a dad to getting cast as a dad and
suddenly being very very busy I just did
one audition and then I think two and a
half months later got the call that I'd
gotten apart they actually moved their
whole family down to New Zealand and
they wound up staying there because of
the experience of the show I didn't know
who I was playing but I suspected it was
a dad normally I either get cast as
homeless or demonic villain so I was
very excited to just play a loving Dad
it's working number 10 another unusual
Story coming your way Sophia explained I
auditioned for this role uh two days
away from giving birth and there were
many a midwife on speed dial saying
please don't go into London she wound up
in London doing her audition and J.A
biota literally had to haul her out of
her camera test chair and they were so
grateful for me to be there number 11.
the mystery never stops rings of power
actor Charlie Vickers not only had an
unusual audition process but when he
showed up it took him several episodes
worth of story to figure out who he was
playing and some of his castmates didn't
know either I certainly was a fan for
before coming onto the project I had
maybe six or seven auditions and when I
got to the end of the audition process
they gave me two monologues one of them
from Richard III and another one from
Paradise Lost a poem by Milton and that
character was literally Satan he had a
feeling that those speeches had
something to do with his character and
that that character was probably pretty
evil or dark we filmed the first two
episodes and then we went on Hiatus
because of covid that whole time I
thought I was playing Hall brand a human
from the Southlands which I think I was
but we need to pause the story here if
you haven't seen the series yet and are
worried about spoilers we suggest you
skip ahead Charlie explained but then
the guys sat me down right before we
started filming the third episode and
they said to me there's more to this
you're playing Soren it was a really
thorough preparation period number 12.
we've got Lloyd Owen as Ellendale and
Lord of the Rings rings of power here's
what he had to say about his experience
my process took 18 months from the first
time I put something on tape he put on
his detective hat and did as much
research as he could getting different
sides with every audition even having an
hour and a half long Zoom call with JD
Payne that allowed him to get more
information
I should never have pulled the elf on
boat number 13. there was a lot of
secrecy around the audition material
here's what actor Maxim baldry had to
say about his experience I didn't know
who I was playing I auditioned for a
young Mercurial guy with the weight of
the world on his shoulders he was very
curious to know who he was playing
making all sorts of guesses and when he
heard that his character loved water he
exclaimed Gollum I'm playing young Golem
oh no but you had your chance
made your choice number 14. Megan
Richards didn't even know the name of
the project rings of power actor Megan
Richards explained when I auditioned it
was called Untitled Amazon Project and I
didn't know who I was playing until I
got to New Zealand I'm really glad that
I have token in my life now it's no
surprise there were some chaotic
audition stories was there anything we
missed about the rings of power
auditions let us know in the comments